ان
[Silence]
ال
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله
الا الله
اشهد
ان
محمد رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محم
مد رسول
[Silence]
الله حي على الصلاه
حي على الصلاه
حي على
الفلا حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فلا مضل له ومن
يدلله فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله وفي بخلق وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وادى
الامانه ونصح الامه وكشف الله تعالى به
غمه وجاهد في الله حق جهاده حتى اتاه
اليقين اما بعد فقال الله سبحانه
وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون ثم اما
بعد ان اصدق الكتاب كتاب الله تعالى وخير
الدي هدي محمد صلى عليه وسلم وشر امور
محدثها وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل
ضلاله في النار رب اشرح لي صدري ويسر لي
امري واحلل عقده من لساني يفقه قولي اللهم
لا سحل الا ما جعلته سحلا وانت تجعل الحزن
اذا شئت سحلا ولا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
العلي العظيم الله ربنا وفقهنا ورجاؤنا
ومولانا فنعم المولا
ونص الله سبحانه
وتالى
اللهانه اللهانه وتالى محد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
سانال
darkness
allowing
الله الله سبالى
‏and think
might الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى قران قران اللهبه
وتالى book of guidance a and happiness
in the world for the worldly life and
the trium in the here for
whoever الله سبحانه وتالى
كتاب انزلناه اليك مباركا ليدبروا اياته
وليتذكر ليتذكر الاول
الباب صلى الله عليه
وسلم تد تفكر
[Silence]
رالرال
قرر الله سبحانه وتالى
شر الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى
الله البقره فذكروني
فذر س بقره
2 الله
استغفار الله سبحانه وتالى قران وما كانما
كان الله معذبهم وهم يستغفرون
[Silence]
الر قران الله سبحانه وتعالى وا اذ ربكم
لان شكرتم
ي س
ابراهيم ادعوني استجب لكم
غفر الله سبحانه وتالى
سران worship times a give to be nice to
folks and do not cut
those relatives of are connected from
the wom meaning the relatives that we
have reflect upon this what a great
outcome the great honor for a person to
remember
اللهانه الله سانال
[Silence]
‏as
a الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
الحد
اللهانه اللهانه وتذ
‏yes he can dy us can finish us
inate us into dust where can that dust
go
astion in the
books
came and approached
سال sons to to burn him as soon as he
passed to burn him which is not
‏make take
all الله سحانه وتالى ق مقت الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله
[Silence]
مقتال البقره فذكروني اذكركم
‏bl t
he thead
happ الله سبحانه وتالى فكرون
الله سبحانه
وتال
people
[Silence]
اللهبه
الله
الله حديث ابو حريره رضي الله عنه الله
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول الله
تعالى انا عند ظن عبدي
به وانا معه اذا ذكرني فان ذكرني في نفسي
ذكرته في نفسي وان ذكرني في ملا ان ذكرت
في ملا خير من او كما قال عليه الصلاه
والسلام
حديث ابو
حول الله سبحانه وتالى يعني حديث القدسي
الله as
my
first الله سبحانه وتالى
ان شاء
الله انا معه اذا
ذكرني ذرني في
نفس في نفسي ذكرته وذكرني في نفسه ذرته في
نفسي
الله سبحانه
وتالى وان ذكر فملا ذكرته ملا خير منه
[Silence]
‏all because
‏open
الله حثش رول صل علس الله سبحانه وتالى يا
الله حسا
لا اله الا الله
محول الله س محمد صل
[Silence]
علمول
صلس my
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى رسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وشه رضي عن حديث كانبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ذكر الله على كل احيانه رسول الله صلى
عليه وسلم
‏remember allah in all
ccan and of almighty can be a general or
specific so the general remem is the
heart the tongs and the limbs and very
righteous deeds of الله
سانتال
for الله سبحان
وتالى servitude of almighty and
magnifying him and loving him and hoping
him and fearing him and ‏and venera him
and the proof of that is the account of
a
man was called to
immortal morality by a woman of a high
status and he
responded
so
uc
ى somebody offers you something that is
against your religion you tell them no
اللهانه
[Silence]
وخار اله الا
اللهب اكبر
[Silence]
وما كان اللهما كان الله معذبهم وهم
يستغفر الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله i would trans different words
وما كان
الله
الله الله سبان وتالى ابن ع رضي عن
[Silence]
حول
‏yes there was people died things
people there was was
from
صلم الله سبحانه وتالى رحمه
العالم
mercy second
[Silence]
‏thr and spit out which call the of and
that's the
where as
الله سبحانه
وتالى حثس الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتالى لا اله الا انت سبحانك اني كنت من
الظالمين
الله سبحانه
وتعالى اقولوا ما تسمعون استغفر الله لي
ولكم وسائر المسلمين منكل ثم فاغفره انه
الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد
لله الحمد لله الواحد الاحد الفرض الصمد
الذي لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله سبحانه
وتالى we
noty
somebody only
شا
life شا
الله
dig follow make you come back in we
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى
فتل ادم من ربه كلمات فتاب عليه انه هو
تواب اليم الله
ا words and
ac
mer سبانه
و الله سبحانه وتالى
فنسي ادم
فن we
got
dna for the was
فتلقى ادم من رب الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى الله
[Silence]
‏me a schar you me person who
famous a
poet
fammi grav
towards my oh
remember say
weam the
words to ask repentance
فتاب عليه ان هو هو هو التواب
[Silence]
اليم ربنا ذلنا انفسنا وان لم تغفر لنا
وترحمنا لنا خاسرين
الله فان لم تغفر لنا
وتمنا
منرين ان شاء
الله دعا
لا اله الا انت سبحانك اني كنت من
الظمين
اللهانه اللهانه
‏supplications
ands and we do not what
time
space
times other to do not utter words that
are destructive towards yourself or your
family mers or your
pr i grew up most of you know the st now
i up in lib
‏and and mothers had a very nice tong to
usually scold you with and one the one
of the famous things that mothers us tob
wasy you
know sometimes supplication
accept so we should be very careful the
words that out of the mth as was always
even in pain if your family is in
trouble and people you
‏people
[Silence]
اللهم اللهم على ذم الا غفرته ولا هما الا
فرجته ولا كرما الا نفسته ولا ميتا الا
رحمته ولا مريضا الا شافيته ولا دين الا
قضته ولا مجاهد في سبيلك صرت على د الا
احلقت ولا ضالا الا هديت ولا عيبا الا
سطرت ولا حاجه من حنض قزيت يسرت لنا اللهم
ان كان رزقنا في السماء فانزله و ان كان
رزق في الارض فاخرج ان كان بعيدا فقربه ان
كان قريبا فيسره كان قليلا فكثير كان
كثيرا ف فيه واعلموا ان الله قد امركم
امرا بدا في نفسه و ثل بكم معشر جن انس
قال عز قائما عليما ان الله وملائكته
يصلون على النبي يا ايها الذين امن صلوا
عليه وسلم تسليما اللهم سلم وبارك وعن و
على عبدك محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين عباد
الله ان الله يامركم بالعدل والاحسان وتاء
ذ القربى وفشك بغي يعزكم لعلكم تذكرون
اذكر الله العظيم يذكركم واشكركم وذكر
الله اكبر وقوموا الى ص يرحمكم الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله
استت الصف
الخل شاء الله
سبحانه الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن الرحم ويل لكل همزه
لمزه الذي جمع مالا
وعدده يحسب ان مه
اخلده
كلا
لينبذن في
الحطمه
وما ادراك ما
الحطمه نار الله
الموقده
التي تطلع على
الافئده انها
عليهم
مؤصده في
عمد
ممدده الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله
الرحمن الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم
الله اذا جا
جاء نصر الله
والفتح ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفره
انه كان
توابا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام علكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته ما
شا
الله so we we have some both of us
up ان شاء
الله شاء الله
[Silence]
‏by
‏that so i conate them all for wonderful
ach there will be a sign out there that
you see
andad great and
inre the same time we are also you know
the construction pr and
be
class ‏any
don
and i know most of you
here make serv for
[Silence]
الله انء
الله ح
[Silence]
الله
السلام
[Silence]
السلام الحمد لله رب
عل ان شا
الله ان شا الله
‏r so we have sister r who take with us
so you come for i'll hand you this
m repeat after me
[Silence]
اوكي
اوكي معت
[Silence]
شاءء the sister has given her the words
so i say
best
comm اهد
[Silence]
اشهد
ان لا اله ال الا
الله اشهد
انا
محمد
تكبير تكبير
تكبير الله سبحانه وتالى
‏gu
bl isam may prov all the avenues and
helps that she needs in her life and
enlighten her and make her pathways
blessed upon congratulations
s that's the only sign langage i know so
accept that from me and if you guys
don't know this means thank you language
الحمد
منور نشوفك على خير ان شاء الله نشوفك ان
شاء الله ان شاء الله ان شاء
[Silence]
‏j
الله
[Silence]
‏eh
‏l
[Silence]
‏b